digamos que este de aquí es un triángulo
equilátero y lo que quiero hacer es
formar otra figura que esté fuera de
este triángulo y lo voy a hacer tomando
cada uno de estos lados del triángulo y
voy a dividirlo en tres secciones
iguales ok digamos yo sé que a lo mejor
el dibujo puede fallar de hecho quizás o
más bien seguramente esto ni siquiera es
un triángulo equilátero pero bueno vamos
a usar toda nuestra imaginación posible
para que se entienda lo que quiero decir
entonces ya que tenemos cada lado
dividido en tres secciones iguales ahora
lo que voy a hacer es colocar un
triángulo equilátero en cada uno de
estos de estas secciones con esa
longitud digamos que digamos aquí está
mi primer triángulo equilátero aquí
tengo mi segundo triángulo equilátero y
aquí tengo mi tercer triángulo
equilátero más o menos espero se
entienda bien la idea que quiero hacer y
no solo voy a hacer eso sino que
nuevamente voy a dividir cada uno de
estos lados lo voy a dividir en
secciones
iguales en tres secciones iguales aquí
aquí quizás debería corregir un poco
mejor el dibujo
y corregir un poco ahí está entonces
dividimos nuevamente en tres secciones
iguales cada uno de estos lados y
volvemos a hacer lo mismo en cada uno de
estos lados colocó un triángulo
equilátero que esté colocado en esa en
esa sección muy bien yo sé que esto va a
ser un poco tardado pero quiero que se
entienda muy bien la idea de qué es lo
que estamos haciendo y esto lo hacemos
en cada uno de estos lados que ya no me
faltan tantos ya no voy a ser tan
preciso en la división de los lados pero
bueno esta es la idea de cómo ir
construyendo el copo de nieve este que
de hecho parece más o menos como un copo
de nieve y ahora que ya tenemos esta
figura podemos volver a utilizar el
mismo la misma iteración en cada uno de
los lados vamos a poner un triángulo
equilátero puesto en el a la mitad
digamos de de cada uno de esos lados si
dividimos los lados en tres en tres
secciones
idénticos muy bien entonces uno puede
seguir de esta forma una infinidad de
veces una infinidad de veces ok y
justamente cuando uno lo hace una una
infinidad de ocasiones obviamente esto
esto no tiene sentido este en la
realidad verdad porque no va a ver a
alguien ahí haciendo todos estos dibujos
por durante toda la eternidad pero si
tiene sentido en digamos en términos
matemáticos y si uno sigue de esta forma
hasta hasta el infinito uno construye
una figura que se le conoce como el copo
de nieve de cojo lo quizás se diga coche
no estoy muy seguro de la pronunciación
pero es el copo de nieve
voy a pronunciarlo como coach ok y esta
figura se debe a este señor que se
encuentra aquí este es el huevón con que
fue un matemático suizo y que fue de los
primeros en construir este tipo de
figuras con su copo de nieve que ahora
se les conoce con el nombre de fractales
aunque este fue uno de los primeros
fractales que se construyeron en la
historia de la de la humanidad y se les
conoce como fractales porque son tienen
una propiedad de ser autos similares es
decir si uno se fija por ejemplo en esta
parte en realidad lo que uno va a ver es
esencialmente esta figura no más o menos
con sus respectivos triángulos y si uno
hace un zoom in digamos si nos acercamos
vamos a ver exactamente la misma figura
en ese sentido es que es auto similar
además digamos la frontera de este de
este copo de nieve la curva que rodea al
copo de nieve digamos ya que lo hicimos
una infinidad de veces es continua es
decir no no no
pegamos nunca el lápiz pero no puede uno
definir una recta tangente en ningún
punto es decir si has visto los vídeos
de cálculo podemos decir que esta curva
no es derivable ni diferenciable en
ningún lado y eso es algo muy
interesante ahora no sólo eso esta curva
es muy muy interesante también porque
tiene un perímetro infinito y para
mostrarte más o menos eso déjame
construir digamos me voy a fijar solo en
este lado y entonces tenemos
tenemos algo así
algo así
muy bien aunque de hecho voy a voy a voy
a reducirlo primero sólo tenemos un
segmento inicial digamos que tiene
longitud s y después en la primera
iteración de como construimos le
colocamos digamos un chipote de forma
triangular que lo construimos al dividir
el segmento en tres partes iguales
verdad éste ahora mide s sobre 3 este
mide s sobre 3 y este mide s sobre 3 y
este triángulo que le construimos aquí
es equilátero entonces cada uno de sus
lados mide igual que la base y eso es s
sobre 3 y s sobre 3 entonces la longitud
de la digamos de esta nueva curva es en
realidad esta ya no me interesa si no
voy a recorrerla en este sentido y ahora
que cuánto mide cuánto mide esta curva
que pinte en rosa pues en realidad cada
uno de estos lados mide s tercios y
ahora tengo 4 entonces son cuatro veces
ese entre tres o lo que es lo mismo 4
entre 3 muy bien y eso es válido para él
para solo un lado entonces qué es lo que
vamos a tener que en nuestro digamos que
tenemos un perímetro inicial que sería
el del triángulo equilátero y el
perímetro en la primera iteración pues
va a ser cuatro tercios del perímetro
inicial verdad porque si para cada lado
tenemos que en la siguiente iteración
tenemos cuatro tercios de ese lado pues
en total vamos a tener cuatro tercios
del perímetro verdad vamos a tener que
sumar tres veces esto o qué sé yo luego
en la siguiente iteración en la
siguiente iteración va a ocurrir
exactamente lo mismo por esta propiedad
de ser fractal le será auto similar
verdad ahora esto va a estar hecho en
esta escala digamos para este pedazo y
va a ser cuatro tercios de la longitud
de este segmento en la siguiente
iteración que eso se traduce en
perímetro a que sea cuatro tercios del
perímetro en el paso 1 entonces si
nosotros nos seguimos vamos a tener que
el perímetro
cuando lo hacemos una infinidad de veces
pues en realidad por ejemplo aquí en
para el paso 2 tenemos cuatro tercios
del perímetro inicial pero el perímetro
inicial es cuatro tercios del perímetro
no perdón no era el perímetro inicial
sino del perímetro al paso 1 y el
perímetro al paso 1 es cuatro tercios
del perímetro inicial entonces aquí
tendremos cuatro tercios de cuatro
tercios del perímetro inicial y así
vamos a multiplicar cuatro tercios una
infinidad de veces pero cuatro tercios
es un número más grande que uno y eso se
va bola décima de fort muy rápido hacia
infinito entonces la longitud de esta
digamos de la curva que resulta al
aplicar esta iteración de una infinidad
de veces su longitud es infinito
su longitud perdón es infinita y por sí
mismo este resultado ya es genial pero
además tiene otra propiedad y que es que
la curva tiene un área finita es decir
siempre está acotada por alguna región
por ejemplo si nos fijamos en este
triángulo
en el pico de ese triángulo y ponemos
una línea digamos que sea paralela a
este lado del perímetro del perdón de la
curva inicial entonces hacemos
exactamente lo mismo para este para este
pico también lo mismo para este pico muy
bien también para este otro pico para
este otro también bueno aquí me falta
poner un poco más nos seguimos y para
este otro entonces si nos damos cuenta
no importa que tantos
triangulitos vaya uno colocando en
realidad siempre estamos acotados por un
hexágono y este hexágono es fijo y el
hexágono fijo tiene un área finita no
tiene un área infinita o bien también
podemos acotar digamos por una
circunferencia o bueno un intento de
circunferencia
más o menos espero se entienda la idea
el punto es que nuestro copo de nieve de
coj está contenida en una región que es
finita es decir tiene un área bien
definida muy bien entonces esto en sí
mismo ya es sorprendente primero que
tiene la propiedad de ser fractal que
digamos es auto similar si hacemos un
zoom si nos acercamos tanto como
queramos vamos a ver esencialmente la
misma figura además tiene un perímetro
infinito y está contenida en un área
finita está acotada y esto a lo mejor tú
puedes decir hoy está muy abstracto pero
no que a lo mejor no se encuentra en el
mundo real pero hay un bonito
experimento de la gente que se dedica a
este a este mundo de los fractales y es
el de calcular digamos el perímetro de
la isla de de todo el perímetro de
inglaterra digamos que más o menos se ve
algo así yo sé que es pero hagas ahora
si un muy bonito ejercicio de
imaginación y imagínate qué es esto es
la isla d
de que está es inglaterra digamos ok
y bueno vamos a tratar de aproximar
digamos el perímetro de esta curva
entonces esto puede ser como algo así
aproximamos más o menos así no muy bien
y más o menos podemos aproximar con
segmentos pero tú podrás decir oye esta
es una muy mala aproximación qué tal si
hacemos un zoom in o un acercamiento de
este lado qué tal si hacemos un
acercamiento y eso se va a ver más o
menos no sé a lo mejor se puede ver como
como algo así no en realidad y nosotros
lo que hicimos fue aproximar de esta
forma así entonces esta no es una buena
aproximación una buena aproximación
sería irnos recorriendo todos estos
lugares hitos ahora bien qué tal si
hacemos otra aproximación en este en
esta digamos en esta bahía ok entonces a
lo mejor la aproximación se va a ver
como algo así en realidad se ve
de esta forma si aproximamos la bahía y
nosotros habíamos hecho nuestra
aproximación de esta forma y en realidad
una buena aproximación sería irnos de
esta forma y esto lo podemos seguir
haciendo para la isla de para esta isla
o para cualquier continente o lo que tú
quieras de forma indefinida bueno quizás
hasta que lleguemos a un nivel atómico
pero en realidad lo que estamos viendo
con este experimento es que la línea
costera de un aislado de un continente o
de lo que sea es en realidad algo más o
menos fractal que tiene algo así como un
perímetro infinito y quizás no llegues a
un nivel atómico así que no será tal
cual un fractal pero es a grandes rasgos
el mismo fenómeno y de hecho es muy
interesante pensar en todas estas
propiedades